I don't know that anyone can accurately
state what Martin Luther King jr. would
say what I can say is based on his
readings and his writings and his
messages had he lived first I should say
I think we would be on a different
trajectory because he was killed and he
did not get to finish the work that he
started a lot of things did not come
into fruition now if he was just to
appear today I imagined he would be very
concerned about the direction that some
of our leadership is taking us in
particularly the political leadership
was little discourse on both sides but
he certainly would be very concerned
about the fact that we're still
consistently engaging in war he used to
say we must learn non-violence or will
face non-existence and he'd be very
concerned about racial injustice that
exists for many in our society today
that that should not and I think finally
he would be working diligently to bring
our nation together to make this the
nation that it can become that it has
not become yet